[Music]
hi i'm rio and i'm the owner of kim su
chamber repair
today i'm doing a resolution on a pair
of gucci loafers that retail for around
one thousand dollars
one of my customers brought me her shoe
that was beaten by her dog
the biggest problem with this shoe is
that her dog shoot the tall area of a
shoe
so the leather is completely cracked and
broken i'm going to repair broken rather
on the toe area
and also clean the shoe and refinish it
i'm wiping off the dust and debris from
the shoe with a horse hairbrush to
prevent the shoe from any scratches by
the wrist while cleaning the shoe
[Music]
now i'm applying a letter of the sieve
to glue cracked leather pieces
[Music]
i have to be careful when i'm gluing
broken leather pieces not to make more
damage on rather
i'm gently pressing the bite marks to
glue the tone leather back onto the shoe
and then slowly moving a roller over the
leather to make them firmly attached
[Music]
i'm taking some more amounts of the
leather peeler and gently spread the
filler over the cracks with a pallet
knife
until the crack appeals filled
and then tilting the edge of the pallet
knife sideways and gently scraping off
the excess filler
[Music]
now i'm using a rotary tool to sand down
the rather pillar on the damaged surface
until it gets smooth
when i use the rotary tool to stand down
i have to be careful about the control
of pressing force
if i press too hard it could dig the
surface
[Music]
i'm applying a leather cleaner with soft
forced hairbrush to clean the shoe
because a cuttery when the dog plied
with the shoe
[Music]
i am mixing up leather paints to match
the color of the shoe and then applying
it with a quick paint brush to the
repair area
[Music]
[Music]
now i'm applying a leather paint with
acrylic paint brush to repaint color
faded edges of the shoe
[Music]
i'm spraying waterproof spray onto the
shoe to prevent the water from being
observed
[Music]
[Music]
you